me dan este polinomio cuadrática 5x al
cuadrado menos 20 x más 15 y me dicen
que es igual a esto ahora como lleno
aparece al cuadrado yo sé que se trata
de una parábola y más aún se trata de
una parábola que abre o hacia arriba o
abre hacia abajo es decir la gráfica de
ese polinomio se ve algo así o algo así
ahora bien como el término que acompaña
x al cuadrado su coeficiente es positivo
es 5
entonces yo sé que se trata de una
parábola que abre hacia arriba y me
preguntó por cuáles son las coordenadas
de su vértice el vértice en sí es el
punto mínimo en este caso si la parábola
abre hacia arriba el vértice es el punto
mínimo del polinomio cuadrática y en el
caso en el que la para la bola abra
hacia abajo el vértice sería el punto
máximo pero bueno supongamos que la
parábola intersecta al eje x en algo así
que no sé si sea el caso
pero bien entonces quiero encontrar las
coordenadas del vértice y el modo más
sencillo es simplemente aplicar una
fórmula que de hecho es bien conocida y
me dice que la coordenada x del vértice
vamos a escribirla como x vértice es
igual a menos b entre 2 a que quizás
reconozcan como el primer término en la
fórmula cuadrática la razón de eso
podría ser de un modo muy intuitivo
pensada como que este punto el vértice
de su coordenada x está justo entre las
dos raíces de este polinomio cuadrática
pero bueno esto funciona a pesar de que
la parábola no intersecte al eje x y si
sustituyó quien es b b es el coeficiente
que acompaña x y ad es el coeficiente
que acompaña a x al cuadrado de modo que
si sustituyó los valores que
corresponden a esta ecuación
entonces obtengo menos veces sería lo
mismo que menos de en este caso vale
menos 20 así que menos menos 20
2 - 20 entre dos veces
ah vale cinco entonces es 2 por 5
- - 20 es 20 2 por 5 es 10 20 entre 10
es dos así que la coordenada x del
vértice es 2 y cuál es su coordenada y
la coordenada 10 del vértice la puedo
obtener simplemente sustituyendo este
valor de x en mi polinomio cuadrática y
eso me da que la coordenada del vértice
va a ser igual a 5 por 2 al cuadrado
menos 20 por 2 más 15
2 al cuadrado es 4 por 5 es 20 menos 20
por 12 40 entonces 20 menos 40 es menos
2015 es menos 5 de modo que las
coordenadas del vértice de esta parábola
son 2,5 pero bueno no siempre es bueno
simplemente sustituyendo una fórmula
entonces vamos a tratar de minimizar
este polinomio cuadrática directamente y
para ello lo voy a reescribir acá abajo
que es igual a 5 x al cuadrado menos 20
x más 15 el idea ahora es completar el
cuadrado
quiero escribir esto de modo que tenga
un término que tenga que ver con x al
cuadrado es decir voy a reescribir esto
cómo voy a factorizar el 5 y escribir
esto como x al cuadrado menos 20 entre 5
es a 4 menos 4x voy a dejar un espacio
aquí y luego sumar este 15
+ 15 quiero completar el cuadrado para
este caso y recuerden que si tengo algo
de la forma x masa y lo elevó al
cuadrado obtengo x al cuadrado más 2 x
más a tweet
más
al cuadrado
de modo que si solo tengo algo de la
forma x al cuadrado más 2x para
completar el cuadrado tomo el
coeficiente de la equis que en este caso
es 4 los menos 4 perdón lo divido entre
2 y elevó al cuadrado y le sumo eso así
que menos 4 entre 2 es a menos 2 al
cuadrado sería 4 así que sumó 4 pero en
ese caso ya cambié el valor de esta
expresión por lo tanto tengo que restar
también una cantidad equivalente a sumar
este 4 pero aquí el 4 está sumado dentro
de un paréntesis que está multiplicando
por un 5 por lo tanto no solo estoy
sumando 4 estoy sumando 20 de modo que
tengo que restar 20 para balancear la
ecuación y esto se convierte entonces en
5 por esto ahora ya es un cuadrado
perfecto y es x 2 al cuadrado
15 - 20 es menos 5
ahora bien noten que este cacho de aquí
siempre es un número que es mayor o
igual a 05 es positivo x menos 2 al
cuadrado siempre es un número mayor o
igual a cero por lo tanto todo esto es
mayor o igual a cero a menos 5 siempre
le estoy sumando un número no negativo
de modo que para minimizar esta ecuación
tengo que sumarle lo menos posible a
menos 5 y lo menos posible sucede
precisamente cuando x es igual a 2
porque si x es igual a 2 entonces 2
menos 12 0 todo esto se hace 0 y obtengo
el valor de y igual a menos 5 que es
precisamente lo que obtuvimos acá arriba